no one in the history of Esports has had
a posture quite as polarizing as JDM
it's a one versus four awp push out good
shot JDM looks for another he's got this
down to one versus two over commitment
and perhaps a little bit zealous to try
an early end this
Katie gets taken down to the Box what is
that from JDM no matter how many heads
JDM clicked all everyone could talk
about was the way he sat in his chair no
one can play like that
and I still believe that it's just it's
really awkward to look at his feet are
like propped up so he's almost like
horizontal okay so first yeah you got to
get the rocking gun that's like the
first thing
um
so yeah
all right we're pretty good we're here
yeah this is over here but is jdm's
posture actually as bad as it looks and
does having good posture make you better
at video games
all right so before we get into the
video why don't you sit back relax slap
that like button subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications so you
don't miss any of our future videos okay
so it's safe to say that some gamers are
very particular about the way they play
from the tilt of their keyboard to the
position of their mouse pad or the
distance between their nose and monitor
comfort and familiarity are key for a
lot of players performance all of you
guys are wrong the answer is Moses head
was 17
up against your monitor is pretty
standard within the TAC FPS Community
right now but back in the day one player
had everyone scratching their heads
because he looked just a little too
comfortable Josh JDM Marzano is a former
professional CS go offer who was known
for literally lounging while popping
heads in the server JDM AWB on site we
know he can step up gotta find rpk first
can't hit the shot getting pin set from
both sides now he's going to be sure to
finish things off but it's a nice guy
God JDM with the tumble no scope
destroys twists and Sean I started when
I was a baby in my crib but uh
um
been lounging ever since jdm's posture
was so ridiculous that it inspired a ton
of memes within the Counter-Strike
community over the years and eventually
it became a big part of his brand
damn it hey don't worry dude don't get
tilted tilted tilted tilted
ah yes that's right Josh Marzano JDM is
it
yes sir don't worry choppers on the way
it'll be on the ground in 20 minutes you
need your ass in the show match bud but
jdm's posture has also left some people
including his former teammates
questioning whether or not it's good for
his long-term Health yeah when I saw JDM
lounging I was a little worried for our
team in general no one can play like
that
and I still believe that it's just it's
really awkward to look at his feet are
like propped up so he's almost like
horizontal now part part of the issue
could stem from the fact that racing
style chairs are used at practically
every Esports event even though they
don't exactly provide much back support
this is something we covered in our
video about gaming chairs earlier this
year but your chair isn't the only thing
that affects your performance a few
years ago former Counter-Strike Pro and
Coach Ron Rambo Kim released a video
about how the position of your table and
chair affects your aim and here's what
he had to say let's say you have a chair
that's too low or a table that's too
high you are now forced to either shrug
your shoulder upwards
lean your body sideways and or
disconnect and raise your elbow higher
if your table is too low or your chair
is too high you'll have to hunt your
back and shoulders and lean forward into
a bad posture position or the opposite
where you'll have to lean backwards now
you'll know that JDM did in fact lean
backwards but Rambo spoke about jdm's
posture in a separate video and no this
is not a pre-game photo this is actually
how he sits for all his matches again
another player who got used to sitting a
certain way and stuck with it all the
way to the professional level if JDM
asked me for any coaching tips on the
way he sits or try to help him to get
better at aiming I wouldn't tell him a
single thing because he got to the pro
level with these positions and if I
asked him to change I guarantee he would
play worse now when Rambo says that he
wouldn't tell JDM to change his posture
he is of course speaking from a
performance standpoint but it doesn't
take an ergonomics export to tell you
that jdm's posture probably isn't very
good for his long-term Health but
luckily it just so happened to No One
Garrick Foreman is a PhD candidate at
Brock University specializing in neuro
mechanics and ergonomics you may
remember him from past episodes of
cracked and we brought him back to ask
him about jdm's posture it's an
interesting posture it's not something
that I
would expect to cease from a pro it was
surprising to me to see him you know
kind of tilted way back kind of the
opposite he would think for a lot of
people slouching when gaming
um you know leaning back a bit more of a
relaxed posture I do do still see a bit
of craning in the neck so I would expect
that to be an issue long term is some
neck pain
um as well as some low back issues
because when we start to slouch we put
our spine into flexion which is not
typically where we want the low back to
be is designed to be relatively flat or
a little bit extended based on their
vertebrae and the discs as we've seen
the idea of a proper gaming posture
develop over the years more and more
players have actually pushed their
bodies in the other direction slouching
closer and closer towards their monitors
but similar JDM this too can have an
adverse effect on your body down the
line especially when it comes to how
hard it is on your neck muscles when
people have neck fatigue or neck pain
they've been shown to be very similar so
just playing through the day or you know
eight to ten hours of practice for a lot
of these Esports athletes your neck will
start to become fatigue because I know a
lot of them are leaning far forward to
get really close to the screen really
fatigues those muscles so that results
in decreased proprioception at the
shoulder the elbow and the wrist joint
so that ultimately then leads to your
body is not really responding how you
think it is and when you are moving to a
spot like let's say you you're moving
you know towards the right with your
cursor your body might not get to the
point that you want it to because you
have you're lacking that proprioceptive
ability to tell where your joints are
now throughout his career JDM truly was
an anomaly nobody lounged quite like he
did and nobody understood how he could
compete at the highest level of play
while looking like he was ready to take
a nap in his chair but what we wanted to
know was whether or not there was
actually a correlation between gaming
posture and performance in the server
unfortunately there just isn't a ton of
research out there that looks into how
sitting position could potentially
affect performance in video games but
Garrick did notice some Trends while
conducting some of his own work I
actually just finished a study that was
looking at competitive valorant players
and kind of looked at high ranked
players versus low ranked players just
to see if there's anything different in
terms of performance and we found that
high ranked players had the monitor
position significantly closer to their
face and were in probably in my opinion
much better postures more upright more
neutral they were they really set up
their workstation to ice and give them
the best Advantage best position to play
their game whereas lower ranked players
had the monitor a little bit further
forward they leaned further forward with
their upper body their neck was tilted
forward so they just as a whole had
worse postures funnily enough even JDM
has come around over the years and
worked towards the more neutral posture
of many modern day competitors although
it likely took time for him to get
adjusted to his new seating position it
was definitely a good decision for the
long run and I'm sure there are some of
you out there who are watching this
video and thinking that perhaps it's
time to investigate your own posture but
how do you break habits that you've been
forming over years even decades and now
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about all right I'm not exactly
an expert when it comes to perfect
posture but I do have some tips that can
help you get started if you're trying to
improve yours
then let's be real these all came from
Garrick anyway first up try setting a
timer on your phone for 5 or 10 minutes
and really focus on sitting in a neutral
position until the timer goes off once
it does you can get up maybe walk around
your room stretch if you need to and sit
back down if you're wondering if your
posture is neutral here's some key
things to check is your head leaning
forwards or backwards are the muscles in
your neck relaxed are your shoulders
flexed in towards your neck and is your
back in a relatively straight line from
your head to your hips with some sort of
Lumbar arch support as you get more and
more used to sitting up straight you can
gradually start to increase that timer
and then just rinse and repeat the goal
of all this is to help your body get
used to sitting in a neutral posture
without putting too much strain on your
back or the other muscles in your body
obviously we're all different so this
might be a quick process or it could
take a while just use your best judgment
because you know your body better than
anyone so I just recommend a slow build
for anybody who wants to improve their
posture for someone who sits a lot I
would I would say probably would take a
few weeks maybe a month until you're a
bit more comfortable with it because you
don't want to go all in you know it's
just like if you haven't been working
out at the gym very much you go in and
you do you know 20 sets of squats 20
sets at deadlifts you're not gonna be
able to walk the next day so and you
might never try to get we often don't
think about the impact that sitting can
have on the muscles in our body because
well it's just sitting but some
well-directed exercise can actually have
a huge impact if you like me spend a lot
of your time sitting at your desk I may
be the poster child of never going to
the gym but we're not talking about
Schwarzenegger level workouts here low
impact and mostly body weight exercise
focusing on areas like your lower back
core shoulders chest and neck can help
your body hold a healthy posture for
longer periods with less fatigue in your
muscles this isn't a workout Channel
obviously so I recommend that you turn
to some other experts if you're looking
for specific exercise sizes to do but
always remember that your form is way
more important than doing a million reps
or lifting heavier and heavier weights
and always remember to stretch because
flexibility is just as important as
strength here want proof you should get
a little sweat in if you want to hit
gold more comfortably look no further
than the massive investment Esports
teams have made into physical trainers
it's pretty clear if you want to play
your best you can't ignore your body as
we've said throughout this episode poor
posture can have long lasting negative
effects on your body but it's never too
late to make a change if you're guilty
of slouching or leaning a little too far
back maybe it's time to give some of
these exercises a try and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about so there you go posture is as it
turns out a pretty complex subject and
it's something that requires still a ton
of research when it comes to Esports but
who knows if we'd even be talking about
it today without competitors like JDM he
was doing something that no other player
could even fathom reclining while
hitting op shots on some of Cs Go's
biggest stages and although he has since
learned to sit up straight we will
always fondly remember Lounge Nation
lounging is life if you're not allowed
you're not trying
you gotta get some Flash in there Sam
get some flash just type in Flash ruler
into Google Flash the famous Starcraft
Pro used to measure the distance between
his mouse pad and keyboard at
competition with a literal ruler very
famous thing flash used to do before any
of these Esports players were like with
that level of regimentation